John Wick is a contract killer with a
mile high body count beloved vintage
cars and a soft spot for little pups
what he isn't is real but what if he was
we assembled experts in the fields of
law psychology and Firearms to analyze
his movies as if they really happen and
give a professional analysis of his
adventures if I had to advise him in the
moment whether he was going to use a
knife a gun or a library book I would
advise library book all day every day
this is if John Wick were real
[Music]
my name is Dr Drea letamendi and I am a
clinical psychologist my name is Doug
Ridley and I am a criminal defense
attorney I'm Jonathan Ferguson keeper of
firearms and artillery for the Royal
armory museum here in the UK in John
Wick 1 this retired assassin returns to
his craft when a low-level mob goon
kills his dog one of the most
unforgivable acts put to film but the
psychological effects of that assault
may have run even deeper the loss of
that dog becomes more than the loss of
an animal companion it is devastating
for him it is like losing everything
that he has this happens shortly after
his wife dies so there is this compound
trauma when traumas happen together we
can't really disentangle it and in his
mind he's combined the loss of his wife
with the loss of his dog needless to say
if you mess with John Wick's dog you're
dead but what kind of legal Jeopardy
does Jon put himself in during the first
of his many shootouts well when all of
the bad guys are coming in to try to
kill John Wick at the beginning of that
first movie initially they are all home
Invaders so John actually has the
ability to defend himself and to defend
his home that's what the law is just
about universally in almost every state
in the country so somebody comes into
John's house with a gun pointed at him
and he has reason to believe that
they're going to kill him he is
absolutely within his rights of
self-defense to go ahead and kill them
first the threat is there and it's real
and it's apparent where it gets a little
sticky is kind of what happens later how
about the gun play is Keanu handling
himself well right off the bat the
strugging thing about the shootouts in
the first movie is how sort of stripped
down they feel and although John Wick is
Benchmark action movie for Golden Era in
terms of how well shot everything is how
Keanu trains and the selection of
weapons and everything he's clearly
slower the then he becomes with more
training between movies more deliberate
and is reloading but the fact that the
reloading is in there was just fantastic
at the time and when in doubt just
follow the rule of cool and grab the
craziest looking gun you can find for
the sake of Cinema
the Kel-Tec SG is a little bit off the
wall but that's the kind of perceived
Prestige firearm that a criminal might
well have two magazine tubes we don't
see John switch between them I guess he
must in order to fire as many shots as
he does he handles it very well it's
extremely cool the sound effects in that
first film are just great that
threatening shot off to the side and
then he racks it again intimidation cool
factor it's it's all there of course
back to the start of John Wick one with
a house full of dead bodies John can
still claim self-defense but when he
calls the cleanup crew his legal
Jeopardy Begins the cleanup crew is kind
of where this all falls apart from a
John did the right thing analysis when
he makes the phone call puts his coins
down and summons the cleaning crew in
he's looking to eliminate any evidence
of a crime and we even see at one point
where the officer this this young deputy
comes to the door and knocks on the door
Nino's Dan Amwell what's going on with
John he knows what's happening and he
just turns around and walks away I'll
leave you be then it's pretty clear that
he's not looking to be involved in the
system in any way I would also say that
when John brings in the cleaning Crew He
is engaged in the destruction of
evidence he is engaged in potentially
destroying dead bodies and there are
some very rarely used code sections that
would criminalize destroying a dead body
without the proper license and all of
those things I think that John probably
has a much bigger things going on than
being worried about what he did to a
dead body
so his four film long crime spree kicks
off
Revenge killing have any chance of
bringing him closer to finding inner
peace it's very natural for us to want
to get revenge especially towards
someone who's wronged us psychological
injury is so painful and so real and
visceral that it's very human to want to
go after the person who's wronged us an
eye for an eye is a really sort of
relatable phrase and eye for an eye John
the reality is that the science of
Revenge does not confirm that taking
some kind of action to balance the
scales really makes any difference in
our grief or reconciling the feelings
that we have in fact if we fixate on
Revenge and we try to find a resolution
in that way sometimes it can kind of
keep us in a mode of unresolved grief we
tend to not find emotional peace we tend
to not find resolution and we're not not
giving ourselves the chance to really
heal from the initial incident of trauma
John's mental trauma turns into physical
trauma for everyone else throughout the
series but aside from all the murder
what other charges could an ambitious
prosecutor tack on jaywalking reckless
driving the man's an honest-to-god Horse
Thief by the second film if we focus in
on just the horse it's hard to talk
about the horse theft with a straight
face but he could arguably be liable for
stealing a horse and depending on the
laws of the jurisdiction stealing a farm
animal could have some additional
enhancements also there is an emergency
defense there as well he's trying to get
away to save his own life if if I went
on the street right now and got into a
car and started it and drove it off the
street but my intention wasn't to steal
it my intention was to get away from the
person who's trying to shoot me in the
head I've got a decent defense on that
that same analysis would go for the
horse in the same way because he is
trying to escape and he is using it for
that purpose okay fine scratch horse
thief from his record but back to the
murder is there any chance that the
world of Assassins could be immune from
federal law could a lawyer claim that
their parallel world of rules and
neutral territory makes them something
akin to the Vatican or an Indian
Reservation every once in a while we'd
have somebody who would come into the
courthouse and try to argue that they
were a sovereign citizen they went deep
into the weeds in the internet and found
some research that claimed that maybe
the laws of the state and the government
and and this country didn't apply to
them it fails universally all the time
and even though John Wick's government
and the continental and and the high
table and all of that certainly has a
lot more going on than the random person
that searched on the Google it actually
really doesn't make that big of a
difference just because they have this
infrastructure and they have a hierarchy
and all of that doesn't mean that they
can claim that they're not subject the
laws of the country unfortunately still
for a bunch of insane ruthless Killers
why do they bother to have so many laws
in the first place because of the
recklessness and propensity for violence
among members of the organization it's
probably more helpful it probably
developed over time to have guard rails
amongst the society so that it's not all
chaos and Havoc there has to be some
semblance of organization and a
hierarchy rules
without them we live with the animals
with this Syndicate the hierarchy is
very very clear you forget that the
roost is bound by the height table and
the height table stands above all who
you take direction from who you follow
who you need to forgive all of that is
pretty clear in the hierarchy assassins
even have their own underground stores
and services most memorably in the form
of the sommelier I'd like a tasting what
is our own firearms expert think about
this movie version's offerings take it
away Jonathan this possibly is my
favorite scene in the whole franchise
the whole idea as they're expanding the
lore of this assassin Universe it just
worked so well to have someone who
suggests your weapons for you absolutely
love that idea the room is actually
packed with other firearms that I was
too excited to even pay attention to
first time around a number of Uzis
there's an m79 tucked in the corner
there just casually propped up not very
Hitman friendly but hey given how things
go down later on in the movie maybe
should have packed one of those as well
I know of your past fondness for the
German varietals but I can
wholeheartedly endorse the new breed of
austrians interesting he goes with
whatever the Somalia tells him to go in
rather than questioning it
um this is the big switch from the HK
p30l that he had in the first movie to
the Glocks Glock 34. 26. on the face of
it the glock's a great choice 34 giving
you a longer Barrel in theory maybe a
little bit more accuracy and ever so
slight increase in muzzle velocity
aren't a huge help in terms of actually
trying to fight people but um it has a
lot of screen presence and it's a Glock
you know legendary combat Police Service
pistols civilians of Defense you name it
competition as well the main reason that
an assassin might not go for a Glock
potentially if there's some sort of
elite assassin like John's supposed to
be is the trigger on the standard block
is not great but sort of mushy and
sludgy and indistinct you might expect
him to have a custom trigger and this
comes with a custom trigger and he has
the little baby brother the Glock 26
um as a sort of holdout gun comes in
very handy later on as well it's one
thing to convincingly sell guns but now
let's see how well John handles them in
the iconic Cavern shootout of John Wick
2. the idea of staging the long guns so
you don't walk in with them and to hide
the guns where you don't immediately
need them ready for use was a really
cool aspect to the whole Hitman thing
because in the scheme of things John
doesn't do so much hit Manning as to the
choices any AR-15 is a good choice this
is a bit of a race gun but not nothing
too excessive little stubby vertical
grip compensator as they say well if
you're firing you're taking on a lot of
bad guys as it turns out you have to do
the one to six variable optic they were
becoming extremely popular at this time
or had become in the sporting world so
definitely on Trend which is amusing
given the whole sort of fashion wine
connoisseur Vibe of this whole scene I'm
flattered to be asked what I would
choose um I can't replace the the
adaptable Peter serafinowitz in this
role but to be honest don't I might well
go for something similar I like the
slightly less race gun Vibe of the HK in
the first movie but if I get to shoot a
handgun I like shoot blocks so I'd
probably still go for a Glock um why not
go for a fancy one the AR I cannot
criticize that Joyce at all I'd
recommend something similar as well a
bit critical of the switch to pistol
caliber later on I would stick with
controllable caliber like 5.56
relatively high capacity he goes for
extended magazines even though in the
shootout he actually reloads more than
he needs to
foreign
and the Benelli I can't know how cool
that is it leads to one of the coolest
takedowns of the entire franchise
bracing the guy against the wall while
he reloads and I guess the only
questionable aspect is if you need a
shotgun why not just stage more
magazines for your rifle what's the
benefit of the shotgun other than Keanu
was doing a lot of three gun competition
and he and the director really wanted
three guns
the one crucial thing John neglected to
bring down there ear protection having
been to that location where they filmed
the big shootout it's going to be
Extremely Loud down there
a lot of this was filmed with blank
firing Firearms blanks are not quite so
Punchy as real live rounds but they're
still very loud so how would they cope
with that well in-ear hearing protection
is extremely good now you can get custom
fitted in-ear hearing protection that is
electronic and it takes out all the top
end and saves your hearing that's how
they Protected Their Hearing in real
life I'm sure and if you're going to do
this in real life as well as getting
your guns your suit whatever else you
would get earplugs John kills so many
people in these sometimes it makes you
wonder is he merely doing what it takes
to complete his mission or is part of
him just doing this for The Rush In some
ways John Wick isn't satisfied with one
or two killings I think you're addicted
to it
to the Vengeance it's all you have he is
somewhat obsessed and fixated with
hunting down every single person and
their Associates who have anything to do
with stealing his car and abusing his
dog to death and in some ways this
series of actions can be emotionally
cathartic for him in the same way that
he's driving his car in the abandoned
Airfield mowing people down with guns is
another way that he's getting this
adrenaline fix it is absolutely
processing some emotions in him again
it's probably not very reparative and
certainly not very adaptive but that's
sort of the John Wick style of handling
difficult emotions so he handles
emotions poorly at times
his weapons with perfection even
everyday objects turned deadly in his
hands he once killed three men in a bar
with a pencil I know I've heard the
story pencil so maybe to avoid further
legal troubles he could stick to the
more creative methods if I had to advise
him in the moment whether he was going
to use a knife a gun or a library book I
would advise library book all day every
day in Most states we have enhancements
for using a firearm it makes it a more
serious crime we have enhancements for
using a deadly weapon it makes it a more
serious crime so if the charges
eventually end up being murder and then
it's murder with a firearm there's a
bigger penalty there's not anything in
the law right now about an extra penalty
for death by library book so I would say
go with the library book all day it's
also a lot more interesting well there
you have it use a book so the judge
won't throw the book at you so after all
these films he's legally in the clear
right at the end of the day there's no
way that John could unwind and just make
himself right with our justice system
with everything that he's done in his
life without just committing to being
behind bars for the rest of his life
there's no way that that story ends if
we're trying to resolve it within our
criminal justice system with John ever
walking free oh well I guess John Wick
will just have to go to jail quietly
then bayliff arrest that man no anyone
all right fine one more Killing Spree
just one you're getting too old for this
yeah
foreign
[Music]